hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the passion or
emotional response of anger is one of
the most violent and troubling that
human beings have to experience and the
starts took a very uncompromising
attitude towards anger different than
some of the other philosophical schools
which saw some usefulness to it or
perhaps even some sign of a good
character in anger the stoic saw it as
uniformly bad and Happiness is following
that a classic stoic position lead in
this is a strong emotion the strong
emotions as sort of you know confusions
of the soul stemming from mistaken
viewpoints on things and shaking us you
know and steering us into things are
uniformly bad this doesn't mean that all
emotions are necessarily bad but
certainly the emotional response of
anger for epictetus is going to be so
although will also be one that is
understandable so it's not you know
purely irrational in the sense that it
just comes out of nowhere and overcomes
us and then steers us into things there
actually the reasoning process involved
in anger is indeed there is in all of
the emotions according to the Stoics so
what are the components that are going
into anger in general now epictetus
doesn't spell this out quite so
explicitly but well well look at what he
does have to say about it in his own
words in just a moment there are some
components that are going into anger as
an emotion even again the stomach's are
not the only people to identify these
this is fairly common in in ancient
philosophy across the schools there's
some sort of one with the stomachs we
call an appearance of Phantasia combined
it was the judgment on that appearance
that that thing that that is showing
itself to us that the other person the
one that we're going to get angry at did
us some sort of harm and perhaps we
could even add here there's usually an
assumption going along with it that they
meant to do that then they were
deliberate about it or they were so
careless that you know it's their fault
that we got hurt so it could be anything
from spilling somebody's drink to you
know saying and insensitive comment in
their earshot to going out to them and
pushing them and saying hey get out of
here or saying a cutting word
deliberately
to hurt them the scope of anger is is
you know far beyond just one's own
person we see people get angry at their
favorite television characters being you
know in cubed in one way or another we
see people get into very heated
discussions about fictional things that
never existed and fictional universes
and what is canonical and what is not
and we could go on and on and on then
the main the main issue here is that
there is some sort of perception of the
other person as doing harm whether out
of contempt out
you know deliberate you know Satanism or
anything in between
and so there's a judgment going on here
that's that's one of the things that you
have to have in order to have anger
along with that there's an associated
desire to retaliate against that person
or perhaps against you know an effigy of
that person or to retaliate in some
other way or if there's a desire to harm
in return to insult and return to
humiliate in return there's also a
desire and epictetus doesn't really
spell this out but we see this happening
a lot there's a desire quite often to
want the other person to admit that they
were wrong right and that's gonna be
totally fruitless and we'll see why in a
moment so why would this desire to
retaliate or you might say it sort of
diffused into that desire it is a
judgment that retaliation is a good
thing that imposing a bad thing on
somebody else it is a good thing that
doing something that would ordinarily be
wrong to do if one was the aggressor is
right to do in the circumstances all
these sorts of judgments are built into
the emotion of anger so you see how
complex anger is when we begin to
analyze it it's not something whose
features we were you know always you
know very acutely conscious of we feel
it rather than thinking that there is a
thought process going on here usually
are the thinking when we're angry tends
to be more how can I get that SOP you
know in these circumstances how can i
attain my vindication or my retribution
now there's a few things in epictetus is
going to point out even book one that I
want to particularly call your attention
to there are other things that are
important in other books you know for
instance where he talks about
habituation and anger I'm going to
reserve that for another core concept
video
and I just want to focus on these three
main things one that's very important
and he talks about this in chapter 15 of
book 1 we don't actually have control
over other people's anger now what does
that mean does that mean that we can't
provoke them into being angry no if we
know we know what somebody's buttons are
or we know in general how human beings
are we can get people angry but it's not
us that are the you know the you might
say the final determinative Clause of
that it's the way their own Faculty of
choice their reasoning faculty their
highest faculty the hegemony home the
way it's arranged and simply go to
somebody that you know has anger issues
and you start messing with them you can
pretty much be guaranteed that they're
going to get angry and they are angry
because you're providing an occasion for
it and you might say you know I've sort
of impulse but they're the main reason
they're angry is because that's the way
that they are you know geared to
responding to things because of the way
they they have come to be structured you
know similarly we can say people from
certain societies or cultures people of
different temperaments may be more prone
to anger than others but when we're
worried as the example here in in
chapter 15 is somebody comes to
epictetus me says my brother's angry at
me I want to I want to not to be angry
with me what can I get up Epictetus says
that's out of your control other
people's prior ASIS is not something
that lies within your control you have
control over your pro I raises your
faculty of choice what you do is
yourself you don't actually have control
over what happens inside of his head or
within his heart he has to come to you
know deal with that himself bring him to
talk to me and maybe I could talk some
sense into him
but I'm not going to be able to give you
anything that you can take to him and
actually you know from an anger
management
this is really good in place because
when you've gotten people in
relationships that already have a long
history with each other presumably these
two brothers do there's a tendency not
to want to listen even when the other
person is talking sense not to want to
listen to them and so the third party
can come in and say listen your your you
know your thought processes are all on
the back here you really don't want to
rethink the way that you're acting
towards your brother and the emotion
that you're holding on to so we don't
actually have control over other
people's anger that lies outside of the
scope of our own you know purpose or
faculty choice that lies in the realm of
things that we do not have power over
and so we should not preoccupy ourselves
with that or else we're going to make
yourself miserable as a matter of fact
you know if we want to extend this
advice think about if you're in any sort
of position of authority you're always
going to have people that aren't happy
with the job that you're doing or if
you're writing and you're putting your
work out there there's always going to
be somebody complaining quite a muffin
getting angry or taking offence that's
something that you say it's almost
impossible in the sort of society that
we live in not - sooner or later offend
somebody if you're going to make that a
measure of how you're doing you're
probably not going to be very happy and
you're going to be anxious and troubled
so another about that point now the two
main places where you really talks quite
a bit about anger a chapter 18 and then
chapter 28 in chapter 28 the discussion
is a little bit more about general
processes of reasoning and I'm going to
talk about that more in another video
but he is going to hit on two really
important points in this that can help
us not to be angry which is the goal for
Stoics right not to be angry so much at
first that's being angry so walking at
first and then eventually hopefully not
to be angry with anybody whatsoever not
even ourselves so here's the two general
points if we can understand why people
act as they
we can feel a different response we can
feel whether you want to translate the
Greek name as the most of name as pity
which tends to have a sort of Jordan
can--it a Shannara tech or as compassion
which it seems a good thing in our time
the degree term is the same that would
translate both of those it's a response
to the other that says you know okay I
can't really do anything about the fact
that you feel that way I wish it wasn't
that that way you're badly olaf and i
feel for you as we would often say we
can feel that response rather than anger
when those people do indeed act badly
from an objective point of view he uses
examples here of thieves people stealing
things and he uses examples adulterers
they are not behaving you know even
though they think that it's the right
way for them to behave they are not
behaving in a way that actually is right
they are mistaken about some pretty
fundamental things perhaps in you know
general perhaps they they've got some
sort of problem that keeps them from
seeing how their reactions actually fall
under that rule we wouldn't have to go
too deep into speculation about that I
mean all you got to do is walk around
and watch people who listen to their
conversations and you know you'll get
plenty of material to this so on that's
the first point when we understand why
people are behaving in the bad way is
that they are what about actually
negating the bad in that case but we are
saying okay I can I can feel for them
rather than feeling like I needed to
retaliate against them the other thing
is we get angry this is for us we get
angry because we're miss identifying
what really matters for us what really
is us what really is in our control or
what really
is up to us and we thereby think
ourselves to be harmed or wrong if
somebody does something to me say you
know accuse my reputation somebody puts
a nasty comment on one of my my videos
dr. Sandler is a terrible teacher and I
don't know why they let him you know in
any university and what he should be off
of youtube and bla bla bla bla bla does
that really affect me from a stoic
perspective that affects something
external to me which is how other people
look at me but there's nothing mature
that says that I have to take that and
you know incorporated it to my own point
of view and say although so and so it
isn't like I've been harmed as as a
result and something is it well you know
what that big Jesus actually said the
great advice well if they actually knew
more about me and they might have worse
things to say about me and then it sort
of blow it off you know that person
doesn't really know what they're talking
about and you know we can say the same
thing for all sorts of other things
somebody cuts you off in traffic are
they really trying to hurt you as a
result or let's say they are trying to
hurt you they're trying to beat you up
right you know we've got this mistaken
perspective if you are beaten up that's
just from a stoic perspective that's
just your body that's not you you still
control how are you as a human being who
has a Faculty of choice is going to
react to what you're going to make of it
I know this sounds rather harsh and this
somebody was beating me up I am a
certainly would not be acting once
knowing like that but I you know from a
stoic perspective I'm not fully along
the way [ __ ] that way to be quite nice
now looking through passages that
illustrate this so let's start by the
second one first he says
here we go this is from chapter 18 if
you've been affected in some way that's
not true to nature of the misfortunes of
another pity him do not hate him drop
this readiness to take offense in the
spirit of hatred do not introduce those
words which the multitude in the scent
of the centuries used these are cursed
an abominable fools he says well that's
great how did that you suddenly become
you so suddenly be converted wisdom that
you're angry at pulse if you really have
wisdom then you're not going to be angry
at the fools why then are we angry here
is the key
because we admire the goods of which
those men robbed us for Mark you stop
admiring your clothes and you are not
angry at the man who steals them stop
admiring your wife's duty you're not
angry at her adulterer know that a thief
or an adulterer has no place among the
things that are your own but only among
the things that are another's and that
are not under your control if you give
these things up and count them as
nothing and whom have you still ground
to feel angry but but as long as you
admire these things be angry at yourself
and none of the men who I have just
mentioned for consider you have a fine
and close near neighbor does not you
have a window and wish to hear them he
does not know where in the true good of
man consists of fantasies of consistent
having fine clothes the very same fancy
you also entertained Shelley and I come
that and carry them on why when you show
a cape to gluttonous men and then gulp
it all down to yourself are you not
wanting them to snatch it stop provoking
them stop having a window stop area here
close and this again it sounds something
rather difficult it sounds like waves
worth withdraw from everything that is
indeed Epictetus advice don't get too
attached to the things that you don't
really have control over you know from a
student's perspective for example your
grades your evaluations whether you get
the class that you want whether you
graduate that time whether you know
somebody offers you
at the job fair from the perspective of
a parent you know whether your kid
behaves the way that they'll ought to I
mean all you have to do is have kids for
a little while to babysit and you'll
realize that there are other people who
have very different views on what ought
to be done in any given situation and
you know we can go on and on and on with
this back to the the understanding why
people do the things they do chapter 28
is particularly good about that he says
what is the reason we have sent to
anything the fact that it appears to us
to be so it is impossible to assent to
assent to the thing that appears not to
be so why this is the nature of the
intellect to agree with what is true to
be dissatisfied with what is false and
so on and somebody says some when we get
people who are behaving in a certain way
that we think is off base that you know
would make us angry probably would make
them angry as well we can't indeed
understand their perspective without the
greeting with it we can say AHA that
seems reasonable to them that's why
they're behaving that way it's
unfortunate because they're off base and
so we should pity them rather than
getting angry with them because the
anger isn't actually going to fix
anything they're still going to have the
same screwed up beliefs that they have
the same screwed-up Hammond's the same
screwed-up desires and us getting angry
may you know keep them from doing stuff
to us to the external things for a
little while but it's really not going
to change anything fundamentally so he
uses the example of Medea
he says Medea would you know for those
who don't know should read Euripides
Medea Medea is a woman who is terribly
treatment treated by her husband Jason
who's a real schmuck actually he's one
of the schmuck iasts of the Greek heroes
he has always got other people doing the
heavy lifting for him he only manages to
get the Golden Fleece by effect at least
ducing medea more she chooses him than
anything else and she encouraged some
horrible costs to you know ensure his
safety that he has children with them
then he decides to throw her over and
marry another local princess so she says
no no I learned what horror is I intent
but passion over masterís so birth
thought epic Tina says it is because the
very gratification of her passion and
the taking of vengeance on her husband
she regards is more profitable than the
saving of her children Medea he tells
her children yes but she has deceived
this is the objection show her clearly
then that she is deceived and she will
not do it but as long as you do not show
it what else has she to follow than that
which appears her to her to be true love
it why didn't you angry with her because
the poor woman has gone astray in the
greatest manners and has been
transformed from a human being into a
Viper why do you not if anything rally
rather pity her as we pity the blind in
the hall why do we not pity those who
have been made blind and halt in their
governing faculties when we say that
somebody lacks something that they would
ordinarily be able to use we shouldn't
be angry at them for that we should
actually feel sorry for them is what
epictetus says and medida furnishes sort
of a prime case for this in ancient
literature we can think of many many
other cases as well if we just put our
minds to it we don't even need to do
that necessarily if you're like me I
need to just consult my memories and I
don't even have to go back in time I can
consult my recent memories and have
enough material to work with us to try
to put this sort of thing into practice